Okay.
Well,
last time I was presenting a kind of panorama of economic expansion,
um,
on the whole very upbeat story.
Um,
it helps to explain how the long population growth of the late 16th and early
17th centuries,
uh,
was able to be sustained.
And yet as the final table on last times handout showed,
there's also reason to doubt whether the expansion was sufficient or whether the
new wealth that was being created was well enough distributed in society to
avoid some real problems,
especially real wages continue to fall.
And there were complaints of a growing problem of poverty and vagrancy.
So there are paradoxes in the situation.
And to get the economic expansion into perspective,
we have to look a little more closely at how it actually impacted on people from
different social groups.
Inevitably,
that involves a certain amount of generalization,
but I'll also try to give you examples of people from different groups,
which will help to give it something of a human face.
So let's start by looking as usual at the top and at what was happening to the
landlords,
the Gentry,
the nobility.
It's really one of the striking features of English society in this period that
many of the nobility and gentry identified themselves very closely with economic
innovations.
They're imperative was to maintain and if possible,
expand their estate incomes.
And in doing so they became very deeply involved in the commercial restructuring
of the country's economy.
That's rather unusual for a traditional ruling class on the whole such people
tend to rely more upon their social privileges than upon trying to improve their
competitiveness.
But certainly the gentry and the aristocracy or many of them did make real
efforts of that kind.
Uh,
and you get basically an acceleration of the trends which had already become
visible in the mid 16th century.
A lot more careful management of their estates in order to produce more from
their home farms for the market and in order to get a greater rental income that
often involved extending the use of leasehold tenure,
tenure of land,
just like a modern lease and wiping away the old rather inflexible customary 10
years so that they had a more flexible management of their rental income.
There was also something I touched on last time,
a good deal of reorganizing their estates into enclosed farms for which they
could get better rents.
And in general,
every effort being made to edge rents upwards when opportunity arose.
the landlord class did pretty well.
Of course a lot depended upon the fortunes of particular individuals and their
personal quirks and characteristics.
Uh,
to take,
for example,
the Vernie family who had substantial estates in Buckingham Shirt just to the
northwest of London.
Um,
so Redmond Vernie who lived in the late 16th and dirty 17th centuries,
um,
was a man who was principally interested in forging a political career at court.
That was very expensive.
He had to sink a lot of his income into fortifying his position at the center.
And as a result,
he incurred pretty considerable debts.
Um,
he succeeded quite well.
Uh,
he became King Charles,
the first standard bearer.
In fact,
he died in one of the earliest battles of the English civil war,
bearing the king's standard,
but his son.
So Ralph was a rather different nature.
You actually took a different side in the industry of a war and when the war was
over,
he devoted himself assiduously to restoring and improving the rather depleted
inheritance he received from his father
involved in all the kinds of measures of estate state management that I've
briefly mentioned.
Indeed,
Sir Ralph was so keen to um,
rebuild the family's fortunes,
um,
that when his first wife died,
he remained celibate.
He didn't remarry.
He didn't want any more children.
He didn't want the risk of the estate having to be divided amongst more
children.
Since he already had a number who had survived infancy.
So different personalities,
different outcomes,
but all part of the same process.
In general,
the income of the gentry and the nobility was expanding
and much of it was spent not only upon extending and improving their estates,
but upon various kinds of conspicuous consumption.
It's a great age for the rebuilding of the manor houses of the gentry.
Many of the lovely country houses which still survive,
were built in this period or rebuilt as well as some of the great prodigy houses
of the age,
the Great Mansions Burley House near Stanford,
which is up here in east Anglia or um,
cut the hall in Northampton chips and other very good example that's over here.
The splendid mansion from this period which survives.
They went in for more elaborate furnishing and lifestyles.
And in addition,
this was a period when many of the gentry and the ability,
the wealthier ones began to spend part of the year in London.
It sees the develop the beginnings of the development of what became known as
the London season,
the habit of spending the winter in town and being absent from their estates,
which are run by stewards for long periods of the year.
This resulted in something of a,
an urbanization of gentry culture,
something which has been recently well studied by,
by Julia Merit in a book on the emerging west end of London,
the elite aristocratic enclaves around the royal palaces.
To give you an idea of the kind of proportion of these people who might be in
town in 1632 king Charles the first in the circumstances of a harvest emergency
order the gentry to return to their states to keep order and to see to the needs
of local people.
He had to find 250 members of the nobility and Gentry who were resident in
London didn't go home when they were ordered to do so.
Given that the great gentry and ability numbered perhaps 2000 families,
that's a very significant proportion of them who were resident in London and
we'll find for failing to go home.
Well if this was a good time on the whole for landlords,
if they used the opportunities sensibly,
if we turn to their tenant tree to the Yeoman and husband,
when one finds a more checkered picture,
opportunities to improve incomes were also common amongst the more substantial
farmers.
Those who had a big farm with a substantial surplus to market,
we're actually very well placed to benefit from rising prices and for the growth
of the market for their products,
be it food stuff or agricultural raw materials.
Many of these Yeoman were extremely commercially astute and very good example as
a man called Robert loader is his name whose farm accounts survive from the
1610s.
He lived just to the west of London in the county of [inaudible].
Uh,
Robert loader calculated every year exactly how much money he was making from
different crops.
He took decisions about how to vary his cropping pattern in accordance with
price trends,
especially in the prices which you could get in London,
uh,
and so forth.
He even went so far at one point to as to actually calculate the value of the
Dung that his pigeons deposited it,
his pigeon loft.
He figured it out what it was worth to him if he used it as a fertilizer in his
gardens.
This is,
this is commercial rationality of a high order.
He also,
he also calculated how much money his horse has made for him over and above what
he had to feed them.
He then proceeded to do the same calculation for servants.
Um,
well,
Robert loader had nothing to learn about economic rationality and his basic
attitudes and not untypical of this kind of substantial yeoman farmer.
Many such people were willing to expand their operations if they got the
opportunity.
If land came available on the local land market,
they would snap it up.
They were able to pay higher rents.
They were an excellent competitive position and as a result you get a general
shift in Loland dinged,
done towards the building up of larger farms in the county of Essex,
for example,
here to the east of London.
It's very commercially oriented.
By the early 17th century,
9% approximately of the tenants held 61% of the land built up in these large
yeoman holdings.
And there's abundant evidence of the prosperity of the yeomanry.
It was a great age for them.
This period has been described by historians of housing as the age of the great
rebuilding.
And by that they mean not only the houses of the Gentry,
which I've already mentioned,
but the houses of the yeomanry is a period when many of the farmhouses inherited
from the late medieval period were being remodeled.
It was very common.
For example,
they tended in the late medieval period to be what was known as a whole house.
Um,
uh,
which was basically one large room with some partitions and the fireplace,
which would the smoke from which would just be admitted to a hole in the roof.
Um,
this is a period when you see people building great central chimney stacks so
that they could have fireplaces and get rid of the smoke,
making the whole of the interior more comfortable.
They tended to divide off the top of the house and to make separate private
chambers above and frequently they would add staircases of course,
to get up there.
They might extend their homes in all kinds of ways.
Many of these houses,
the great yeoman houses of this period survive to this day.
When you look at the inventories of these people which were taken when they
died,
they also reveal a marked increase in the value of their household goods and in
the elaboration of the types of goods that people possessed.
William Harrison,
a clergyman who described all of this happening in the later years of
Elizabeth's reign said that despite the fact that higher rents were being paid,
many of the villages in his area,
the yeoman farmers are the ones he was thinking of.
We're able,
he said yet to find the means to obtain and achieve such furniture as here to
for has been unpassable.
And he went on to specify what that involved joined furniture made by join us
proper joined chairs rather than stools.
Nice tables,
bedsteads soft furnishings as a proliferation in inventories of cushions.
And if carpet cloths,
carpets where these would oriental carpets being imported by the Levant Company,
they were put on tables.
You didn't put a carpet on the floor.
It's far too valuable for that.
You put it on the table to decorate the table.
Uh,
some,
uh,
representations of interior scenes in this period show that the carpet across
the table and you find them also having more elaborate table and more elaborate
kitchen where all sorts of odd products turning up in their inventories.
Apple toasters,
for example,
an apple toaster,
something crate and barrel perhaps should try to imitate and to hold in the fire
with an apple in it.
And so on.
All kinds of things.
It's been described by one historian of material culture as a new household
culture with much greater comfort,
much greater convenience being enjoyed by these people.
They could also put their money into other things,
bigger dowries for their daughters so they could marry well.
A study of Kent shows the,
in the reign of Elizabeth,
the dowries being paid by Yeoman with their daughters rose six fold in the
course of her reign.
And they could also spend the money to have their sons apprenticed into trade,
into professions,
sent to school in some cases even to the universities.
Something that returned to and another occasion,
well,
the yeomanry with a big fish of village society,
things were a little more difficult for the little minnows.
The smaller guys,
the family farming Husbandman,
some of them did fine.
If they live near a city,
they might have good marketing opportunities.
They could specialize in producing fruit or market gardening or dairying and
could do pretty well.
You also get a lot of husband when diversifying their activities into part time
industrial activity,
uh,
over in the West Midlands in the metalworking districts.
The inventories of,
um,
size makers,
for example,
can be quite interesting,
um,
indicating that these people were engaged in farming,
but also in producing sides.
Blades on the side,
they had forges.
Um,
generally they would work at that in the slack periods of the agricultural year.
But for many of these small guys,
the period was fraught with risk.
The crucial issue was whether they could sustain their small farming economy
under changing conditions.
These were the people who would have most difficulty meeting higher rents.
They might have,
uh,
a poor competitive position.
Uh,
one agricultural writer described them as weak and unstopped husbandman.
They lacked capital,
they produce smaller crops,
they made smaller profits,
they had fewer livestock.
They couldn't really seriously contemplate indulging in expensive or risky
innovations.
And they were also very vulnerable to temporary crises like those produced by
bad harvests,
which could wipe out their surplus and forced them into debt.
Some of these people became vulnerable and we're driven to the wall and their
land was taken up by more ambitious neighbors.
And in general,
there's a diminution in the numbers of these small farmers.
As the big farms are growing,
many of the small ones are disappearing whittling away of small tenancies,
which in turn made it rather difficult for the young to get onto the land to
establish a foothold.
More of the young people from rural families after their period as servants in
the households of larger farmers were more likely to spend their lives as
agricultural wage laborers then getting land of their own.
So the fortunes of different groups in rural society varied.
They're broadly fairly clear.
One can generalize with some confidence in the towns.
The picture's a little less clear.
Clearly there was a lot of commercial development and business opportunity,
but this was a period when business was fraught with risk.
Finding the capital to set up could be difficult.
Keeping businesses going could be difficult in a period when cash flow could be
hard to manage.
People had to keep a good balance between their debts and credits that could be
very difficult.
Accumulation of wealth was often very slow and even the successful could be
wiped out by temporary economic crises.
By fraud,
by fire.
There's no fire insurance by shipwreck does,
no marine insurance and so forth.
It was to try to counter some of these insecurities that some of the principle
merchants of England cities preferred if possible,
to be members of chartered trading companies.
Those companies which had a monopoly of particular branches of trade,
the ones I mentioned last time and which lay down rules for the conduct of the
trade rules,
which were generally aimed at securing stable profits for all the members of the
company and to restrict the numbers of people who were involved in particular
trades.
It's true that no trading monopoly could protect a merchant from shipwreck or
piracy or the collapse of demand,
but nonetheless,
one can generalize to some degree about the way in which they fed.
For some who were members of established companies,
things could go pretty well.
Take for example,
the Levant Company,
the Van Company traded to the Mediterranean,
especially the eastern Mediterranean in 1570 it was founded by the early 17th
century to become a member of the van company meant laying down two to 300
pounds as membership fee.
Quite a substantial sum of money by the early 17th century.
Also,
this company has been described as I'm quoting a highly ramified network of
interconnecting family relationships.
The members of which are often related to one another and controlling a great
share of the trade.
One contemporary described them as born rich and adding wealth to wealth by
trading in a beaten road to wealth.
In 1627 there were only 24 men who controlled 54% of the Levant trade.
So members of the great companies having established the trade could restrict it
in various ways in order to ensure some stability in their trading lives.
It has members of that company who will later to go on to found east India
company.
Well,
in addition though,
there were certain additional opportunities.
Another way to prosper if you had the nerve,
and we'll take the risks.
What's to get involved in pioneering altogether new trades at the most
significant of those where the American traits with the earliest establishment
of colonies in America,
the initial opportunities,
we're not obviously good and many members of established trading companies were
reluctant to invest that left the path open for those who are prepared to take
the risks of involvement.
And very often those have got involved in the American trades where man of
lesser standing in the merchant community,
smaller merchants,
even shopkeepers,
ship's captains,
people like that who are willing to get involved.
New Men,
you could say
they built up
as you know,
a very substantial trade in the course of the early 17th century did.
Just to give you an example of one of these people.
The man called Maurice Thompson.
Mrs. Thompson was the youngest son of a gentry family.
He got a little bit of capital from his family,
but not much more.
He didn't inherit the family estate.
You came from Hartfordshire just sort of north of London.
How He came to go to Virginia is uncertain,
but he was there by the time he was in his mid teens and he got involved on the
ground floor with the development of the tobacco trade.
Uh,
pretty soon he owned land.
He owned a ship.
He became involved in the trade in tobacco and in the supply of goods needed by
the colonists.
She expanded his operations.
He married well.
He became a significant figure amongst the leaders of the Virginia colony as
quite a young man.
By the time he was in his early thirties,
he was back in London,
uh,
managing much of the,
a good part of the Virginia trade from his base there.
And indeed he went on to expand his operations to become involved in the Indian
Ocean and in other ventures if you're interested in that kind of person and that
kind of development.
Um,
Robert Brenna's book,
merchants and revolution.
The first section is a splendid depiction of these shifts and developments in
the last years of Elizabeth and under the early stewards
at lower levels in the urban hierarchy,
the capital that people needed to set up in business was gradually growing.
That made it a little more difficult to establish yourself as an independent
master.
And a great many people had to be content with serving as skilled craftsmen,
working for others,
whereas previously they might have hoped to become independent masters,
even skilled employees,
we're often forced to work longer and more intensively if the work was available
in order to sustain their living standards.
To give you a specific example of this,
I've got some figures here relating to building craftsman from the town of how
on the east coast.
Donald Woodward in a very imaginative piece of research,
worked out the price of food stuffs,
found the wages being paid to craftsman of different kinds,
and then figured out how many days you would need to work to feed husband,
wife,
and three children.
So here are some of his fingers.
The best paid man in the fifties and sixties could have fed their families with
153 days work by the 1630s with rising prices and wages are not rising so fast.
229 days.
The worst paid 192 days in the fifties and sixties 306 by the 1630s so this was
the experience of some of the craftsmen of the towns.
Yeah.
In short then urban manufacturers and the urban manufacturing system was
becoming less small,
master based and rather than more capitalistic Lee structured with a larger
proportion of urban craftsman having to cope with the difficulties and
uncertainties of their dependence upon wage labor.
Okay.
Well,
much of the true,
much of the same was true of the industries of the countryside in Somerset
church in the West country.
Had the cloth industry was the major industry in the 1620s one contemporary
described the multitudes of poor cottages which where to be found in the cloth
weaving areas and he continued.
They are stuffed with poor people which get most of their living by spinning by
carding and such employments about wool and cloth and they gained a living most
of the time,
but he added that when trade was dead.
They know not how to live
in town and country like then what contemporary is described as the laboring
poor
was emerging as a larger,
more wage dependent population emerged probably half the population by the mid
17th century to judge by surviving tax listings,
agricultural intensification and the diversification of industry and urban
growth.
All meant that there was more work for such people,
but the work was often seasonal.
It was often insecure.
There was a lot of under employment difficulty finding five days work a week and
so forth,
and there was the constant pressure of greater numbers of people on the labor
market and it was this really that issued in what's sometimes described as a
problem of structural poverty of large number of people whose way of life,
who's very way of life on a day to day basis meant periodic hardship was almost
inevitable.
Some of the time.
People who faced a situation in which the rate of pay for the Labor was such as
to mean a declining capacity to meet the needs of their households
and that produced a distinct lifecycle amongst the laboring poor.
They could manage pretty well until they had to say to children are so they
might even have a little bit of disposable income to spend on manufactured
goods,
but once they had too many mouths to feed or if the chief breadwinners felt sick
or injured or if there was a trading depression,
they could be plunged immediately into real hardship and in old age,
if they reached old age,
they almost inevitably would be dependent upon charity.
Many of these people survived by what's been described as an economy of
makeshifts.
It's a phrase of all when Huffington's and economy of make shifts,
you get by as best you can,
doing what you can cottaging where they could using the Commons if they were
available,
gleaning the fields after the harvest.
The poor were allowed to glean for grains of corn in the fields after harvest
and finding various kinds of assistance from their family,
from their neighbors moving around when there seemed to be better opportunities
to piece together a living.
And for that reason they tended to become concentrated in certain areas where
there's opportunities existed.
It was a rather unsettled life for many of them.
I'll give you a couple of examples of these people.
Um,
Margaret Noseley,
she came from Nantwich in Cheshire.
There's a name she's visible in the wreck chords between 1613 and 1629 she was
married to a laborer.
We know that she had 10 children between 16,
13 and 1629 five of her children died in infancy.
Something of her working life survives in various records.
She worked as an alewife making and selling Ale.
She worked as an agricultural laborer during the appropriate seasons.
She did some stocking knitting.
She acted as a cleaner for the minister of the parish.
Um,
she's thought to have practiced some forms of medical skills.
She had some skills in aspects of midwifery.
Apparently she was alleged also from time to time to have solicited men for
money.
So that's an economy of make shifts indeed or another.
Such person,
Henry Savory.
He's visible in the records between 16,
29 and 1636,
he came from sto,
barred off in the county of Suffolk.
We know a little about Henry and 1629,
he was,
uh,
he was a servant.
He left service and instead of engaging himself to a new master,
decided to go to London.
Once he got to London,
he found it difficult to find regular work.
So he signed on for a voyage on a ship.
Uh,
but he wasn't a very good sailor.
By the time the ship had got out into the Thames estuary,
he was suffering from chronic seasickness and his legs were swelling up.
So finding him,
no use to him.
The ship master put into shore and just landed him and discharged him.
He went back to London.
Then he was taken by the constables as a vagrant and sent home to stove,
barred off in 1635 he decided to try it,
his fortunes again.
He left stow barred off after haymaking where he'd earned a total of seven
shillings.
He had seven shillings in his purse.
He went to the county of Suffolk,
uh,
further into the county of Suffolk and worked in various farms there for three
months and then he went off to London again once again.
He found it difficult to find regular work,
so he began working up and down the country as he described it.
He got as far north as New York and then made his way back again back in London.
He found himself once again,
arrested as a vagrant and sent home to Norfolk and there we lose track of Henry
Savory.
He vanishes from the records.
That's exactly the kind of person moving around,
trying to earn a living where he could,
who might've been the sort of person who would have signed on with a ship master
in London to become an indentured servant in the new colonies in Virginia and
Maryland.
And indeed many people who found their way to London but couldn't find a place
there did just that.
Uh,
in London there was an institution charged with the oversight of the vagrant
poor.
Uh,
the bridewell and the governors of the bridewell actually dispatched over 1100
people to Virginia and the West indies between 16,
18 and 1658.
At first,
they were mostly men,
about 90% men,
but by the 1630s,
about a third of them are close to a third world women.
Two thirds of these people who were sent had been taken by the officers on the
streets of London.
Some of them were accused of crime.
They might've been accused of being picked pockets or thieves,
but most of them was simply out on the streets.
They were described as out after curfew or night walkers that was just loitering
suspiciously on the streets at night.
Um,
some of them were former servants who had no place and we're on the streets.
Uh,
and they were sent by the bridewell to the new colonies.
one of those who was sent gave his occupation as balancing it,
which makes me wonder if that's the origins of country music.
Um,
I'm serious.
in the,
uh,
in the early 20th century songs connected by folklorists in the Appalachians,
many of those songs can actually be traced back to print balance,
which are known to have been sung on the streets of London in the late 16th and
dirty 17th centuries.
They did,
they passed into the oral culture of the Appalachian area.
Well,
one can go on about these people is a wonderful recent book by Paul Griffiths
called Las London's,
which looks closely at them through the records of the Brightwell.
The Brightwell kept excellent records.
They even kept physical descriptions of some of the people they dealt with so
that they could identify them if they turned up again.
And so we have descriptions of,
you know,
their,
their stature,
slender wells set thick set one was described as great,
gutted
their complexion,
you know,
sallow high colored,
bright,
sad,
a sad complexion,
described the hair color flaxen,
dark brown betwixt Orban and flaxen.
All these descriptions are entered in the books,
their clothing,
a woman found on the streets wearing a red petticoat and the white upper bought
us
so poor but colorfully dressed some of course,
uh,
we're beggars who weren't near naked.
You get descriptions also of their medical condition,
you know,
pockmarked in his face,
a small scar upon his forehead burned in the hand.
That means someone had been found guilty of a crime and branded for future
identification and sometimes they were suffering from disease palsy.
Scurvy skulled headed it.
That was very common.
It meant a,
a kind of scalp condition.
Uh,
one man,
one of a boy actually described as his toes,
almost rotted off.
Others were mentally ill,
crack brained,
silly,
simple.
That's how they're described.
Uh,
one description that arrested me when reading this was a northern man by his
speech.
Hi colored beard,
close cut mingled with white hair in a manner crazed.
And then you get those people on the streets of London who had no known
identity,
uh,
you,
they turn up in the past wreck chords.
The parish of sent Bollard Bartholome user,
for example,
gave assistance to a beggar who turned up at the church who had no name.
Uh,
they put him down in their account books as money given to Bothell them.
You need both of them.
You need,
because he came to Saint Bartholomew's church and you find the children who were
left on the streets.
Um,
often when they were taken in by parish authorities,
they would give them a name.
Michael Found Joan found basket baby found in a basket porch wall.
She was found in the porch of the Church of Saint Andrew by the wall.
So they baptized her porch wall and so on.
Could go on Joan mad or those who are sometimes buried in the parish is found
dead on the streets.
John,
no name Jane.
Nobody.
So England's increasing income was very unevenly distributed.
It was an expanding economy,
but one with an expanding problem of structural poverty.
It was a commercializing society in which there were great opportunities,
but many of those who had nothing to sell but their labor.
We're in a poor competitive position and in an exceedingly risky environment.
Of course some aspects of those insecurity where perennial,
but at times they could become particularly acute and the Times that stand out
are the 1590s which was a time when the harvest failed.
Four years in a row,
foot prices rocketed.
The weaknesses in the economy were revealed and there was widespread misery.
Indeed,
in the years,
1596 to 50 98 there was actual famine in the most vulnerable areas.
Parts of the far north northwest in particular and parts of the far west is
evidence of actual death from starvation.
The 1620s was another decade when they were bad harvests combined in this case
with an industrial depression,
war in Europe or dislocated at the markets for some of the goods that England
export it leading to industrial depression.
There was widespread unemployment and poverty in many of the weaving areas and
again,
some sinister evidence of actual famine in some of the most exposed areas.
These were the hardest years,
really acute crisis of that kind of course were exceptional,
but they reveal the weaknesses within society as a whole.
So how to conceptualize all of this.
Very often historians talk about these decades,
these generations at the turn of the 16th and early 17th centuries as witnessing
a process of social polarization and the some obvious truth in that there's a
real divergence going on in living standards and in life chances in a more
competitive commercialized economy,
but it's also in some ways more comp complex than simply the notion of
polarization.
In many ways,
the social structure was re articulating into a sort of three part form.
There were greater opportunities on the one hand to acquire and to consolidate
wealth.
There was a greater population of laboring poor on the other hand,
both of which we've looked at,
but there was also the elaboration of what contemporaries were beginning to
describe as the middle sort of people between the gentry and the poor.
Successful manufacturers and tradesmen,
substantial yeoman farmers,
increasing numbers of people involved in professions like the law and medicine
and the offering of services of other kinds,
surveyors,
Clark's land agents and so far so forth.
So it all depends on how one looks at it.
You can focus your attention upon the real polarization.
You can also take account of these middling groups who are doing quite well.
But whichever way one looks at it,
it's clear that the old medieval conception of a society simply describable in
terms of three estates had gradually decomposed under the pressure of economic
and social change.
And Society was gradually recomposing itself adopting a new shape under the
pressure of various economic fields of force.
And that transition involved not only shifts in the structure of society,
but also shifts in people's attitudes and values.
By the early 17th century decades of cumulative economic and social change meant
that economic relationships and forms of behavior which had previously appeared
new and rather threatening.
We're becoming more normalized,
more taken for granted,
and some traditional values,
we're losing some of their older moral force.
And you can see that in various ways,
but a good example is to look very briefly at the problem of enclosure.
The classic issue of Great Symbolic Significance in agrarian society.
As you know,
in the mid 16th century and closure had been demonized as something which was
damaging to the wellbeing of the Plowman,
to the strength of the nation,
destructive of households and of the Commonwealth and throughout the latest 16th
and early 17th centuries,
actual enclosure schemes were very often opposed by coalitions of tenants and
commoners who tried to defend their customary ways against the initiatives of
landlords and others.
And we look at that again when I look at popular protest.
But meanwhile the debate over enclosure was gradually shifting.
You get that shift reflected in parliament in 1,601 there was a debate on the
enclosure laws and whether or not to repeal them.
Sir Robert Sessile,
son of William sessile,
Elizabeth's chief minister,
speaking on behalf of the Privy Council,
said,
I think that whosoever does not maintain the plow,
destroy earth,
this kingdom very much the traditional attitude towards enclosure,
he was opposed by Sir Walter Raleigh.
Yes,
these Walter Raleigh,
um,
who said he agreed that,
uh,
there was a situation,
which must be faced regarding agricultural change,
but he argued that there were lots of countries in Europe which could produce
corn cheaper than England could and therefore it should be important rather than
insisting upon maintaining land under the plow.
He argued that every man should use this land to its best advantage and she'd be
at liberty to do so.
Leave every man free,
he said,
to pursue his economic interest.
So we have the voice of economic individualism,
opposing sessile
debates like that in parliament reveal a graduate process of transition in
attitudes,
tensions and shifts between older and newer attitudes.
And that tension was revolved in various resolved in various ways,
sometimes by authoritative adjudication,
by government decisions in parliament or the Privy Council,
often by sheer expediency,
by people gradually adjusting themselves voluntarily or reluctantly to the
demands of a changing world.
In the case of enclosure,
gradually most of the gentry and many leading tenant farmers came to accept its
desirability and the laws against it.
When in fact repealed in 1624 leaving people free to use their land as they saw
best as Raleigh had argued.
Well,
the attempts to stabilize and channel change by the use of the law gave way
gradually to attempt simply to alleviate the worst manifestations of change
where it had led to major social distress and the greatest monument to efforts
of that kind where the poor laws,
the crisis years of the nine nineties led to the overhaul and consolidation and
extension by parliament of earlier measures which had been taken in poor relief
resulting in great consolidated statutes of 1598 and 1,601 under those statutes,
a full national system of poor relief was created based upon compulsory local
taxation at the level of the parish administered by officers to be appointed in
every parish
under the laws,
vagrants were to be punished and restrained.
Those who are deemed the impotent poor,
the agent,
the sick,
the orphaned.
We're to be relieved by being paid weekly pensions in their parishes and finally
the laboring poor.
Those who could get by most of the time,
but native needed occasional relief.
We're to be periodically relieved by the parish to enable their families to get
through hard times and where possible work was to be created for them.
So what you have in the poor laws is a mixture of charity and discipline.
In some ways,
the system was quite well devised to deal with the periodic lifecycle crises of
the laboring population.
They'll rarely,
generously,
it was a system which in many ways demonstrated England's relative wealth.
There was a tax base there to pay for it,
but it was one of course which also demonstrated how unequally distributed that
wealth was in one parish.
For example,
the parish of Corsten in Norfolk where the laws were put into operation very
early.
There was 68 people in the parish out of 167 households who were able to pay the
poor rates to support the system.
At the other end of the scale,
there were 20 households who received weekly pensions,
so 68 are paying 20 or receiving pensions,
all the ones in between,
or neither pain nor in receipt of relief.
Though in bad times,
some of those families might receive occasional help.
So the poor laws in a way are both a response to and enshrine some of the
changes which are taken place in society at the local level.
I've surveyed then a process of redistribution of wealth in a changing economic
environment.
Economic development had enabled the population of England to grow faster for
longer than was usually the case in other European countries at this time,
but the benefits of economic growth we're poorly distributed and that showed
population at last began to stabilize in the third decade of the 17th century
and that began to slow down this long term process of change.
The reasons for that stabilization,
we're partly shifts in mortality.
The evidence is that life expectation of birth was deteriorating in the early
17th century,
but it was a strained even more by shifts which were taking place in fertility.
Quite significant shifts in the early 17th century.
The rates of fertility that can be calculated from the parish registers of
parishes show that marital fertility was falling quite sharply.
That was produced in part by rising agent marriage.
People were marrying later and having fewer children,
but it was also produced by a larger proportion of the population never marrying
at all.
It was startling when historical demographers discovered that of the people who
were coming up to marriage marriageable age from the 1620s through to the 1650s
people who'd been born around,
um,
1600 to 1610 or thereabouts,
as many as 20% or sometimes even more,
never married to quite extraordinary figure,
a very large proportion of the population remaining unmarried.
What we seem to have here is evidence of a situation in which for those who were
doing least well in the circumstances of the time,
life was too insecure or living standards were too marginal for them to be able
to marry and establish independent households of their own.
As a result,
fertility declined population gradually stabilized
as population stabilized,
so did prices.
The great underlying dynamic of change from the second quarter of the 16th
century through to the mid 17th century was over.
But that long dynamic of population growth,
inflation and its many consequences in economy and society had unleashed
economic changes,
which would not be reversed.
And they had significantly reconfigured the structure of society and the
relationship between its members.
So with that,
I've tried to briefly set the scene for you and now we can go on to look at a
number of other aspects of society and culture starting next week with the
issues of witchcraft and popular literacy and crime.